sau đây là thông báo hồi gỷ lần thứ 12,7.
Thực hiện trước trình là việc tòn quả hồi gỷ lần thứ 12,7.
Học từ ngày 12 tháng 18, đến ngày 17,7.
Tại từ đoài đối.
Mặt chấp hàng trường đàn thống nhất cơ bản đối dung các văn két,
phương vướng công các nhân sự đại hội đại điều tàn Quốc lần thứ 14 của đàn.
Mà gồm, định hướng phân bộ cơ cấu số lượng,
vì viên trường đàn chính thức khoa mề bốn.
Thư trình cơ cấu số lượng vàng miên thắc phần bộ đại điều,
dự đại hội đại điều tàn Quốc lần thứ 14 của đàn.
Chòi kiến về nhanh sự bộ xung cuối hại bộ chính thịt mạnh biệt thư khoa mười bốn,
những khi hay cũng trong 2 mấy sấu hay cũng trong 3 mốt.
Lần trước, hành trưng đàn, lồng ý chủ trưng hợp nhất mà báo cáo,
hồi máo cáo chính thịt, mào cáo kinh tây xấu hội,
mào cáo về tổ kết xây dự đàn và thị hành điều lệ đàn.
Lội dung công thách xây dự đàn, thông quan lự dung cơ bản sự thảo các phân kia
chừng đại hội đại điều tàn Quốc lần thứ 14 của đàn như sau.
Vậy dự thảo báo cá chính trị chính đại hội đại điều tàn Quốc lần thứ 14 của đàn,
bân chức hành trưng đàn, thống nhất đánh giá,
được hợp nhất các báo cáo là thư suy mới, lục phá, thế hiện thách làm sáng tạo,
tránh được sự trường bạp, thiu thống nhất sự các báo cáo,
thế hiện lúc tầm vắc của báo cá chính trị, gió quán điểm, chú chương,
các định mửi chính lục cuộc thề về khách nhiệm vụ trọng tâm các đủ tả chính lực
có tính hành động cao nhất quán,
không vui báo cá chính trị mới là chương trình hành động chung thống nhất.
Vậy dự thảo báo cáo tổng kết một số vấn đề liệu và tự tiến
về công cuộc đối mối theo địa hướng sau hội chủ nghĩa trong 1,5,5,
bàn chấp hành trưa đàn thống nhất đánh giá dự thảo báo cáo đã được ra sốt bộ xung cập nhật
và bảo đầm đồng bộ giữ các báo cáo
bàn chấp hành trưa đàn đồng góc nhiều ý kiến xấu sắc tí tuệ chách nhiệm
giấm tiếp tục phần tiện dự thảo báo cáo, những thành tư hành trế và bài học pin nghiệm
được lúc kết trong tự tiến xây dự chủ nghĩa xấu hội Việt Nam.
Dự báo tình hành quan nghiệm và các định hướng giải pháp tiếp tục đệm mạnh phần tiện
đồng bộ công cuộc đối mối xây dự phát triển đất lúc và bảo vệ tụ cuu trong ra đàn mối
về dự thảo báo cáo tổng kết thì hành dự lệ đàn bàn chấp hành trưa đàn
thống nhất đánh giá dự thảo báo cáo đã tập trung làm gió việc quán chết của thế quán
trên khai thực hiện công tác kịp ra giám sát việc thì hành dự lệ đàn.
Các quy định giữ giảnh của trung luôn về thì hành dự lệ đàn.
Dánh giá khách quan toàn giết xấu sắc việc qua đầm được hành chế có khăn bướng mắt bất cập trong tự nối xung.
Về bộ xung xử đổi đều lệ đàn, mắt cho thành chung đàn tống nhất máo cáo
đã hội đại điều tần cuu glệm tương với bốm của đàn.
Dau măng cho thành chung đàn khoảng 18, lãnh đạo chỉ đạo miếng cử,
tổng kết thực tiến để đầy xử xử đổi.
Bộ xử đều lệ đàn, cương lệnh chính chị sẽ dự nất nước trong thời gian quả độ lệnh chủ nghiệp xa hội.
Chỉnh đại hội bởi lắm của đàn vào 10 mũ trăm năm thành lập đàn.
Một gì chế chăm băm, mười hai hiệm không chăm băm, mười.
Lệnh hướng lỗi dung và giá bộ chính chế chỉ đạo các cơ quan chức năng,
tính hành nghiên cứu tổng kết thực tiến tiền hàng điều lệnh đàn.
Nguyai từ đầu hực kì để máo cáo kết có thẩm quyền xem sách,
lệ sách bộ dung, sờ đổi điều lệnh đàn.
Mắt cho thành chung đàn giá bộ chính chế,
cân cứu ý kiến thảo lực của chúng ương.
Máo cáo tiếp thu giả chình của bộ chính chế để chỉ đạo tiêu mắt vật kiet.
Têu mắt kích tây xa hội và têu mắt điều lệnh đàn tiếp thuộc,
hành chiến sự thảo các bất kiet trên,
đề hội lệnh ý kiến lại hội đạo bộ các cấp,
giúp kỳ hành hiệm không chăm hai lắm,
hai nghị không chăm băm mười.
Trong khi điện,
không có phức đàn giá bây.
Măn chất hệ hội dung đàn thống nhất các nổi dung đề xuất của đàn quy chính phụ,
về một số nổi dung sờ đổi mồ xung có hiết quyết lỗi của chình bương.
Về nghị quyết xúc mùi tắm của băn chất hành chương đàn,
có mề bà,
về tiếp tục đổi mấy phần thiện thề chế,
chính sách nâng cao hiểu lực kiểu quả quả quả lý và sự rung đất,
thảo đổi lực nơi đất nước ta trở thành nước phát triển có tu nhật cao,
bàn chất hành chương đàn đã thảo lợt thống nhất bộ xung quan điểm chỉ đạo hình nghi quyết xúc mấy tắm,
cho phùa bởi bối cảnh mới,
sự đổi mục tiêu để phùa bối tình hình và khả năng thực hiện trên thực tế,
điều trình bộ xung một số nhé vụ giải pháp,
về nghị quyết xúc hành biệnh của băn chất hành chương đàn của mấy bà,
về tiếp tục xây dựng bà hoàn thiện nhả nước pháp quyền sau ở chủ nghiệp Việt Nam trong thời đận mới,
bàn chất hành chương đàn thống nhất xưa đổi bộ xung lỗi dung,
tăng kưởng xây dựng các đạo lợt có lỗi dung thề khiểu lực trực tiếp trong nghi quyết xúc hành biệnh,
trong hướng chuyển mạnh từ tuy ri quả lý,
sau khi khiến tạo phát triển,
đề cao tính kịt thời, lý hoạt trong xây dựng pháp lợt,
đề đáp ứng yêu cầu phát triển ngành và bởi bứng,
thảo gỡ các dịm ngán bứng mắt về thề chế,
đồng thời nhằm pình định gió dàng hợp lý thầm quyền lập pháp bà lập quy bảo đam yêu cầu
các quy định của pháp lợt phải mở tính ordic có giả trị lâu dài.
Về nghị quế xô hành biệnh chiến của bán chất hành chương đàn pháp với một về đối mất cân bản
con giịn giả giúp và đạo thảo đáp ứng yêu cầu công nghiệp,
hệ đại hoá trong điều kiện khiến tế tị trường định rứng sau chủ nghiệp,
và hội nhập quốc tế, chủ ứng nhật định,
về thử kệ nghị quế xô hành biệnh vẫn còn bú số khó khăn bước mắt,
vực đẩy mạnh tự trụ tài chiến, xả hội hả giáo dụng,
gắn vực sách sảm nâng sách nhả nước đại hưởng đến sự phát triển xả dụt công lập,
đặc liệt ở xả dụt đại hảo giáo dụt kế nghiệp.
Sách định mất lộ tự trụ của các cơ sở sách dụt đào tạo,
chỉ cắt hưởng vào bức lộ tự trụ tài chiến,
làm cạnh trở việc xa ou, và tự kia quyền tự trụ của các cơ sở sách dụt đào tạo,
vắng nhìn cứ khó học. Măn chất thành chung đàn đã thảo lợt thống nhất sử đôi,
bộ xung nghị quế xô hành biệt chiến, nhằm thảo gỡ những khó khăn vướng mắt cóm in nền từ một số lội dung.
Cô hịt quế tài.
Để kết lộn hội gỡ lần thứ xấu,
băn chất thành chung đàn có mở bà, về đi hướng cuối vạch tổng thế cút ra,
về tìa hành hình hành hành hốt thành hình bà mười,
tâm diền đến năm 2020, băn chất thành chung đàn,
bà bà bà bà bà bà bà bà cáo tiếp tù dài trình của bà chính trị.
Để hoàn trình việc xấu đổi bò xung, lỗi dung, các nghi quyết quế tổng trên.
Về đại hội đàn bộ các cấp, băn chất thành chung đàn yếu cầu,
băn tổ chức trung đường, các tình vì thành vì đàn yếu trực thuộc,
khẩn trương trình khai kế hoại tổ chức nài hồ các cấp,
sử lý kìt thời các bứng mắt part sinh, không nè bị đọc, chậm chế,
phọc nè sẽ ra mất bản kết lối bộ.
Bà chức thành chung đàn, khi hành kì lột bằng hình thức,
các trích tất cả cho bộ trông đàn.
Đối với các đồng chiế vệ sôn phục, muyên ở bên bộ chính trị,
muyên trực tích nước, bó bản thường, muyên ở bên bộ chính trị,
muyên trực tích nước, vương đình vệ, muyên ở bên bộ chính trị,
muyên trực tịch của khỏi, lệ bình khái,
muyên ở bên tư trường đàn, muyên phá tư tự trình phụ,
hài trư gia khỏi đàn, lối về đồng chiế vệ tịch kiểm tiến,
muyên ở bên trường đàn, muyên bộ chính bộ ấy tế,
mân trước hành trưng đàn, lồng ý để đồng chiế độ lực suy,
vì bên trưng đàn, bộ chính bộ đung ghế phà môi trường,
thôi giữ trước ở bên bán trước hành trưng đàn của bởi mà,
và đồng chi vọ chỉ công ở bên dưới trưng đàn,
muyên ở bên bán thử bộ thạng ấy,
muyên trường bán tình ráo và dưới phật thạng ấy cần thơ,
thôi giữ trước ở bên dưới bên dưới,
mân trước hành trưng đàn của bởi mà,
mân trước hành trưng đàn cho ai kiến và giên sự,
để bộ chính trị quyết định giới thiệu của gộ pháng người Lam,
phê tròn giữ trước bộ trường bộ đung ghế phà môi trường,
nghiệp kia hành khó trăm hai mốt,
hành hiểu không chăm hai bây sau.
Về bệnh hành môi hình chính quyền điều phương hà cấp,
bàn chắc thành trưng đàn ráo đàn của chiếc phụ,
đàn của ý các thơ quan, đàn trưng đàn,
đàn của ý mặt trận của quốc,
bảo các đoàn thế trưng đàn của ý các tình thành,
tự theo rối sát thì người,
sơ kết tòn diện sau sấu thắng để kiến nghiệp điều trị của tịch tiến,
đàn ráo về kết quả trên khai gị quyết số người tâm của bàn chắc thành chúng ta gà,
bỏ mười hai từ tháng mười mốt năm 2020,
đến tháng 20 năm 2020,
tình gình đất nước sấu thắng đầu năm 2020,
về những công việc quan trọng môi chính trị đã dải quyết từ sau hội nghiệp chúng tôi mười mốt,
đến hội nghiệp chúng tôi mười mười hai,
bà một số những đường trọng tâm đến hội nghiệp chúng tôi mười ba,
quá mười ba.
về những diễn biến mối của tỉ hình thế giới,
khu vực từ sau hội nghiệp chúng tôi mười mốt,
và quan điểm chủ chương của ta.
Bà chấp hành Trung gương kêu gọi tòa đàn,
quan rất phần quân trung sức động lòng,
lỗ lực phần đầu, vượt qua khó khăn thách thức,
bà đàn bà đạo thông sốt,
hiểu qua, hiểu lực của môi hình chính quyền được phương hải cấp,
phần thành thắng lợi như buộc phát triển,
kinh tế sau hội,
năm 2020,
bà tổ chức thành công đại hội đàn cắt cấp,
đến tới đại hội đại biểu tòa nguốc,
lần thứ mười vốn của ta.